PAUL RASHIDI: Hello.
I'm Paul Rashidi with the
Google Cloud Platform team.
Now that Compute Engine is
open for everyone to use,
I thought it'd be fun to
do a demo of using Compute
Engine to set up a
cloud-based web server.
That way you can see the
process and then try it out
for yourself.
Let's get started by
pointing a browser
to cloud.google.com/console.
When you first come
to the cloud console,
you'll be prompted to
create a new project.
We're creating a
test web server,
so we'll call it
Web Server Project.
We'll change the suggested
project ID as well.
And then click Create.
That will start the
creation process.
Now that the project's
been created,
we'll have access to all
of Google Cloud Platform's
services.
Compute Engine is
a paid service.
So the first thing
we'll need to do
is set up our
billing information.
You'll likely be
surprised at how
affordable experimenting
with Compute Engine can be.
I'll go ahead and fill
in my billing details
and be right back.
After we've entered our
billing information,
we'll navigate to the Google
Compute Engine Instances
page, where we'll see a
list of virtual machines
that we've created.
We don't currently have
any, so let's add one.
We're going to create an
instance called Test Web
Server.
Start by clicking the
New Instance button
at the top of the page.
We'll specify the name
as Test Web Server.
For the zone, we'll
select US Central 1B.
For machine type,
since this is a test,
we'll select the smallest
one available, the F1 micro
with one virtual CPU and just
over a half a gig of RAM.
And we'll go with the suggested
default image, which is Debian.
Our instance is almost ready.
Some final health
checks are being
run, which is the last
step before the server is
ready to use.
There, now our instance
has been created.
So by default,
Google Compute Engine
blocks all connections to an
instance from the internet.
Since we want to serve web
pages from our instance,
we'll need to set up
a firewall to specify
that incoming HTTP traffic is
allowed on the network where
our newly created
virtual machine resides.
We'll do that by
clicking Networks.
Select a default
network, which is
where we created
our virtual machine.
Click the new link that appears
at the top of the firewall
section.
Name the firewall http1.
In the Protocol and Ports
field, enter TCP 80.
Click the Create
button to complete
the creation of the firewall.
Once this process
completes, we should
see the new firewall appear
in the firewalls list.
And there it is.
Now that the network
where the virtual machine
instance resides has
a firewall configured
to allow internet access,
let's install a web server
on our virtual machine.
In order to make changes
like installing software
on our Compute Engine
virtual machine,
we need to remotely
access the machine.
The Google Compute Engine
team has created a great tool
for doing this
called gcutil, which
is included in the
Google Cloud SDK.
The instructions for downloading
and installing Google Cloud SDK
can be found at
developer.google.com/cloud/SDK.
You'll essentially
download it as a file,
extract it, and run
an install script.
Then run an
authentication script
and grant the tool access.
I'll go ahead and finish
speeding through this process
now.
The authentication
command here is
what grants the SDK access
to work with your project.
An OAuth2 token is
being issued and stored.
We're now set up to use gcutil.
Once gcutil is installed
on our machine,
we can use it to remotely
access the instance we created.
There's a quick way
to do this if you
go to the Instance Details page.
On the side,
there's an SSH link.
Copy the SSH command
that's provided there.
Open a Terminal Window and
paste the SSH command into it.
You're prompted
for a pass phrase.
Enter something you can
remember for SSH keys.
Here we are in the command
line of our virtual machine
instance.
Let's install some software,
specifically some web server
software.
The web server software we're
going to install is Apache.
A standard command used on Linux
to install software is apt-get.
We'll use that.
So we're going to type
sudo to run the command
as a super user,
apt-get install apache2.
It's going to ask us to confirm
that we want to install it.
Hit y and type Enter.
The installation
process has started.
And now Apache has
been installed.
As part of the
installation process,
Apache creates a
default web page.
We can try unloading that
default web page in a web
browser to confirm that we're
actually serving web pages.
So let's jump back
to a browser to test
is we can load the default web
page that Apache has created.
Now, to find our
default page, we
need to know the internet
address of our server.
We'll get that on
the VM Instances
page of the Cloud Console.
We can see our external
IP address here.
Open a new tab and
type the IP address.
And here we have the
default Apache web page.
Great, our test web server
is serving up pages.
Now to prove that this
is our web server,
let's modify the
default web page.
We'll start typing sudo to run
the command as a super user,
then nano, which is a
text editor we'll use,
and then the location of
the Apache default web page,
which is var/www/index.html.
When we run that, it
opens up the index.
file and the nano text editor.
We'll remove the default
text that's there.
And then we'll
paste in an image,
so that we can easily tell
the page has been modified.
We'll save the page in nano
by pressing the Command
key and the X key
at the same time.
And then type y to save
the file and close nano.
Back in the browser, we should
be able to Refresh the page.
And there's our new
custom default web page.
Now, I would call
this test a success.
The final thing we need
to do to wrap up our test
is to delete the virtual machine
and persistent disk we created.
As I do that, let's
make a calculation
about how much this
whole test cost.
So to delete the virtual
machine and persistent disk,
first we'll select our
test web server VM.
Then scroll down and click the
Delete Disk Instance button.
We'll check the option for
deleting the boot disk as well.
And then click OK.
Our deletion
process has started.
The current virtual machine
price for the type we use
is 1.9 cents per hour.
We ran our server for
around 10 minutes.
So our virtual
machine usage cost
comes in at just under
a third of a cent.
And there we go.
The virtual machine
has just been deleted.
Now, back to pricing.
The persistent disk pricing is
$0.04 per gigabyte per month.
So that roughly comes to
just under half a cent
for a 500 gigabyte
boot disk, the default.
So everything we just
did on Compute Engine,
we did for less than $0.01.
Thanks for watching.
Now, it's your turn.
Go try creating your own
cloud-based web server
on Compute Engine.